you know a lot of people send me their
desert chicken okay I get a lot of a lot
a lot a lot of tags for desert chicken
I've seen you know I've seen it all the
wings of the sprinkles and you know
actual chicken that's you know ice cream
or chicken covered in ice cream whatever
maybe you know candied glaze perhaps
yeah but this one this one dare I say it
man takes the cake
oh I like that cuz we moving on from
dessert chicken what do we got here what
do we have here
somes like a turkey right yeah nice
delicious turkey psyche it's a cake no
way it's a cake that looks like a chart
charbroiled turkey roast a smoked turkey
yeah that's a sting no that's awesome
you kidding me this is what you see on
Thanksgiving um was it like it's like
some Peter Pan [ __ ] like when other
people cut into you know Turkey they
just see the meat but you when is the
possibility yeah you see sweetness you
see sugar do you think this is actually
like maybe the outside is actually
smoked like they've made a cake and they
I mean they covered it and then they
actually like smoked it so it's like a
little sweet little savory man that
could be the way you said that yeah the
way you said that I kind of got a you
know yeah a delicious yeah maybe some
corn salad on the side but it's actually
marshmallows or sprinkles ya know with
gravy marshmallows of the grape on a
chicken wing out of the [ __ ] fro just
a fry oats as a frozen piece of raw
chicken oh and add the sound effects
I like this girl's username to a
cheating vegan that's good yeah that's
solid vegan cake looking like a
charbroiled turkey that's genius
I don't think it's her cake no no but
I'm just saying oh you're liking it yeah
yeah yeah that is a good it's a good
it's a good commentary you know on just
like the food industry yeah general yeah
subverting yeah norms with art you know
why can't why can't turkey be cake did I
bring my coffee in yes mom uh-oh seen
your car okay sometimes I guess I'm
gonna have to just be like relaxed and
yeah and not take a [ __ ] at precisely
the end go at someone needs to make a
compilation of all the times you've ran
out to take a dump I spent like three
times there's been three tops no there's
definitely in the in the insane asylum
studio yeah you've done a few okay maybe
it's yeah maybe it's in the in the teens
[Laughter]
you